this is david rawlings he is a master of
swordsmanship and weapon arts with over
25 years experience and is the founder
of the london longsword academy today
he's looking at some of the weapons and
fighting styles from the brutal battles
of chivalry 2. historically we actually
have the use of this kind of weapon as a
way of stopping people getting through
entrance ways and genuinely trying to
stop people from getting onto a boat so
i do like the within injury that you get
so many kind of like incidental melee
weapons that you can pick up that are
fundamentally useless and really really
don't do anything other than give you a
little bit of a like i have a chair
that's really useful
i highly recommend checking out the
london long sword academy all their
links and information will be in the
description but without further ado
let's see what a swordmaster makes of
chivalry too
[Music]
[Applause]
i like it's got all the important
yelling and screaming in general i
really like the combat in chivalry
because it's melee and there's not so
much value in taking these really broad
swings when you've got loads of your
mates and you are just hitting each
other left right and center so you start
learning the value of these down the
float i think when you're dealing with
something like this hammer where you've
got both the hammer and the beak of the
weapon you could look at the potential
of maybe being able to like hook the
corners of shields or pull them forward
this kind of thing or even hook legs but
again i understand the complexities in
trying to animate this but they could be
nice little touches obviously just
battering someone with it very very cool
it's not going to look very much
different to this it might be kind of
nice to see potential for the puncturing
um effect of these things particularly
where it's going into kind of like male
gaps and things like that might be
almost nice to have the effect of not
necessarily going through the armor but
glancing off the armor denting the armor
and then actually breaking in through
one of the gaps in where the chain is or
something like that it's getting a nice
little spike in here so there's things i
can see cosmetically that would be more
difficult and i think would make the um
the survivability of characters too
great in this so i think it's a good
balance between bludgeoning the shite
out of them finding the weak spots
finding the weak spots would be a little
bit nicer but still still very very cool
so the faction in this is very very
interesting i think it's a little bit
more of a starter to my eye something
still has the capacity for cut and
thrust and that'll vary the one that we
seem to have in this you might be
surprised sometimes they're not as heavy
as you might imagine they can still be
quite light they can still be quite
nimble on the other hand they can be
absolutely beasty weapons if you think
you've taken the mass of a big sword and
kind of compacted it down into something
so you still got quite a lot of metal
but like i say that can be deceptive
they can still feel very very light
maneuverable but being excessively good
cutters something like this now this is
not that this is a fashion which is just
horribly horribly nasty and incredibly
incredibly good in the cup this is a
horrible beast of the weather but it
still has the capacity to thrust and i
think this is something that chivalry
has done very very well is that they've
maintained the idea that you can thrust
with pretty much anything even if it's
not so efficient in the thrust so this
should be a good combination cut and
thrust weapon again it's really going to
have the same problems against heavy
armor that is not particularly well
designed to go against plate for example
but it is still going to be relatively
efficient going in through the gaps this
one seems to have a little bit of spike
so here you have a nice point which is
still going to go through gaps and
hopefully as it's still going to go
through a little gaps in chain and that
kind of thing
[Music]
so the falcon flight is really really
cool not so much because of the falcon
but the really interesting thing about
this is really the use of the greatsword
and montante
being used to stop someone getting onto
a boat historically we actually have the
use of this kind of weapon as a way of
stopping people getting through entrance
ways through narrow cars and genuinely
trying to stop people from getting onto
a boat so maybe then trying to get up
the gang bank maybe them trying to get
through the two rows between the oarsmen
this kind of thing depending on the
circumstance so different ways of using
them if you've got people to either side
of you with oars you need to basically
keep yourself as much forwards as
possible so that there's not this right
swinging if you're on a narrow thing
with nothing to either side with none of
your own people you can hit then you can
swing at this with clearance if the
other person has in this case has got a
shorter weapon than you you have a lot
of extra reach they're going to have to
work really hard to get through it and
they're going to get hit on the back
swing for the forward swing so for the
protecting a narrow area that was a
really really interesting fight the guy
actually was genuinely trying to stay
quite in the line and i liked that very
very cool
[Music]
i do like within in chivalry that you
get so many kind of like incidental
melee weapons that you can pick up that
are fundamentally useless and really
really don't do anything other than give
you a little bit of a like i have a
chair that's really useful they have
full armor the chair is completely
ineffective oh i'm dead i think that's a
really nice touch obviously you need a
frying pan of invincibility because that
should be inevitable
[Music]
when you get to any axe in combat the
real big issue that you're going to have
again is when we're dealing with the
amount of armor that people are wearing
the type of armor that people are
wearing really it'd be nice to see
something where quite often than this
you'll hit see something hit the back
and i think you see in the in the clip
you see the axe hit the back and it
looks like it hit straight into the
armor and there's still loads and loads
of blood and i think this would be one
of the nice things to see is that the
armor in itself is much more efficient
at stopping bladed weapons and that
you've really got to go for the bits
which are not using huge amounts of
plate so if you've got a decent
breastplate that's got every potential
to stop this weapon it's not your good
use swinging it horizontally into the
torso not a good use swinging at the
arms good use face good use anything
that's exposed so it's not so much a
critique of the weapon but it kind of
feels like the opponents in this are
still able to be injured in places where
they're exceptionally covered by very
very good armor so i'd like to see the
attacks being more isolated to places
that don't have good protection
[Music]
racehorse my hand is so much to unpack
with these things they can be used by
long swords primarily in treaties that
refer to things like
montante and spadoni they're really not
being used in exactly the same way but
then you get these little giveaway
sentences that say they should be that's
probably down to our training that we
are doing them wrong as humorous and i
started trying to adjust my training to
reflect the fact that they are just
swords and we should be using them like
swords so there's a few other things to
look at first of all the rings everybody
always has a little bit of a fascination
with the rings on a spy handle or beaten
hander and really what i want you to
look at is the idea that they are
nothing more than not to be grabbed hold
of really to hold it like a chainsaw
this is complete nonsense really they
are just a way of stopping your fingers
from getting impacted so very often in
long sword fighting for example you will
find that if you're holding the saw with
any normal grip your hand resting about
here your knuckles will still get hit
and that's really it it's as simple as
that you put a big ring on that and it
stops your knuckles from getting hit in
these incidental strikes so it is just
hand protection really that simple the
other thing is really the lugs that are
further up the blade the little hooks
again i look at that as an extrapolation
of this principle which is they kind of
take the place of the rings that you'd
have on a complex side saw for example
so they're rings to stop something from
impacting down on those bigger sets of
fronts so in this case you have
something that stops the blade from
sliding down and then potentially
hitting onto those rings or missing
those rings because
quite frequently if you're holding the
sword and you've got rings something
impacts and it still manages to hit your
knuckles so if you have something here
or here that stops the blade from
sliding down your blade you have that
additional protection
[Applause]
quite often you do see these okay you do
see people doing this either defensively
or to attack people will grab hold of
really really sharp knives and again
hands are relatively survivable you'd
much rather you lose the use of your
hand and still be able to live than you
want to do anything else now if you
think if you've got a weapon at the same
time as tebow says if someone grabs hold
of your blade they've got the power of
your life in their hands because they
still have a free hand with the sword in
this case you're basically benefiting
from the leverage from the fact that you
can oppose your opponent's blade running
at someone doing this you can but you've
shortened your weapon so it's whether
it's that much use to you but certainly
if we come from here and we've gone
around the opponent's blade if you
imagine pivoting around their blade like
this then gripping stopping their blade
from coming back towards us by
dominating with this double hand
position then chanting this makes a lot
more sense so absolutely it's the thing
you do where you do it i would suggest
is more of the issue in the game
longsword just look at his weapon in two
hands and again all things apply how
much mass there is the construction of
the blade whether it's more of a diamond
section whether it's designed more for
cutting so the profile of the blade is
going to be important but really i don't
think there's anything you can add for a
long saw that can't be said about the
montante or the spadone or the spy hand
of beaten hander for example half sword
absolutely fine his capability to cut or
thrust is going to be somewhat dictated
by the profile of the blade its use
against weapon up against armor is
likewise going to be influenced by that
so if you're wanting to jimmy into the
spaces in armor then that's going to
want to have more of a diamond section
for example just to keep the rigidity in
the blade
the other thing of course is then the
murder stroke okay which is where you
hold the sword like this now this is not
a great weapon for doing this with i do
apologize it's very very very very flat
but holding it by the other end and
booping somebody with it a bit like a
pickaxe that's a thing
when they say stabbing with the pointy
end they mean this is a big weapon what
can i do with all of it
now one of the things i suggest about
this idea of using the weapon um more or
less like a pickaxe where you're kind of
like you're hurling the weapon and
you're hitting them with either the
pommel or the cross guard
is not that it's necessarily the thing
you're going to do as your first thing
but if you've used say you've gone to
the half saw position like this
and having done something and moving
their sword out the way the next most
convenient piece to use is this end then
that's the perfect place for you to do
so so you may have thrown somebody's
sword out of the way and then the next
thing for you to do is to smash them
with the other end to hit them like so
so it's more of a case of rather than
being
necessarily your initial design
it's the prudent and most efficient use
of your weapon from the position you're
in and why disadvantage yourself by
going well you can't do that so i think
what we have to look at is there is a
point where we will do it because it is
the most easy and quickest way to
dispatch our opponent not that we're
going to gear our way through the
fighting game at some point we do
something really sneaky to turn around
hitting with the other end that'll
surprise them no really this end of it's
it's now the simplest and most efficient
way for me to kill them
it's a polar pole arms basically are
going to come down to it what you put on
the end of them so those lugs might be
to stop something moving down the blade
they may be to give you the capacity to
parry briefly as you go through because
parrying with the head of the weapon is
very very much i think you certainly see
this in halberd and it really comes down
to has the weapon got something which
can briefly interrupt something if you
point your point towards it this is kind
of an underexplored or under known
element of carrying that people don't
often think about sometimes we'll carry
not by putting the broad and strong of
the weapon in the way of the blow but by
pointing at the sword and what this
means is that you confront it with a lot
less energy and you absorb the blow by
first of all pointing and then sort of
absorbing the structure into yourself
now that's not as esoteric as it sounds
it just means that you're not
confronting something directly you're
just taking here now if you have
something like a spear you're much more
likely to be able to confront something
with a point but without so much force
so you're more likely to gather the
weapons somewhat like so so having lugs
on the weapon might be to stop an
opponent getting down it it might be
just to prevent it from sliding down
while you're going through this motion
and allowing yourself to get some form
of parrying action as you go through
that
if you'd like to see more of david as
well as other martial and medieval style
episodes make sure to like the video and
let us know in the comments we have
another video on chivalry featuring
david coming soon so be sure to
subscribe for that and if you want to
see more of the london long sword
academy you can check out some of their
videos as well as all their links in the
description below thanks for watching
[Music]
you